- Allow me to put on my
shill hat for a moment.
Everyone else is gonna tell you
what's wrong with Intel's Arc A700 GPUs.
And, we're gonna need
to talk about that too
because it's a pretty sizable list.
I mean, we've got the A770 losing
to a card from almost
10 years ago in CS:GO?
How embarrassing.
But what's this?
It beats and NVIDIA's 3060 in Fortnite.
It absolutely murders the
Radeon 6600 in Ray Trace games,
and is available starting at
just around its $289 msrp.
Something I will never
take for granted again.
So it's with that in mind
that I want to explore
a different perspective.
One where the benefits of competition
may outweigh the risk of buying
into a first generation product.
That's right. It is
time to get blue pilled
with me folks. Or not that one.
I meant like Intel Blue.
Though I am pretty excited right now.
Excited to tell you about our sponsor.
- Ridge. Ridge Wallet has
redefined the traditional wallet
with its compact frame and
R-F-I-D blocking plates.
Because the bulge in your pants,
shouldn't be from your wallet.
Use offer code Linus to save 10%
and get free worldwide shipping.
(machine beeping)
(upbeat music)
- Intel's A750 and A770
GPUs are designed for gaming
at either 1440p with medium
details or 1080p Ultra.
And they've got NVIDIA'S RTX 3060 directly
in their crosshairs, or
at least now they do.
Their transistor count
and power consumption
are both more comparable to the RTX 3070
which would indicate that
Intel fell well short
of their original performance targets,
and is now trying to make
lemonade out of these lemons.
But that's not our problem.
And from a consumer
standpoint, they kind of did.
Because at $289, the A750
may just be the most silicon
per dollar ever in a GPU.
And there are situations
where it really shows.
Check out this performance
in Direct X12 games.
1080p High has NVIDIA's 3060 taking nearly
every game by a thin margin.
But when the resolution gets cranked 1440p
at medium details, it's
Intel racking up small wins
nearly across the board.
And this is against a card
that costs $50 to $100 more.
Even looking closer, the Arc
cards continue to impress.
5% and 1% lows are very
comparable to the RTX 3060
which means you won't
feel any extra hitching
or stuttering in heavy firefights.
And while I was concerned
that Arc might fall flat
on its face in a Horizon system,
that wasn't the case at all.
Oh, and as an extra bonus,
Arc murders the more
price comparable RTX 3050.
Isn't competition great?
This is the point in the
video where Intel's employees
and shareholders might
wanna stop watching.
Because we're about to look at some games
that aren't Direct X12 or Vulcan.
In Shadow of the Tomb Raider,
Arc's performance falls to
nearly half in DirectX 11. Ouch!
And CS:GO, a DirectX 9
title where Arc feels
like a totally different card
every time you start it up.
With the A750 beating the A770 sometimes,
1440p results being
higher than 1080p results
and, oh by the way, no matter
which card you're looking at
they get absolutely wrecked in performance
by the 3050 flagship
GPU from nine years ago.
And probably a competitive Abacus user.
I mean, what happened to
crush Intel's performance
in these older titles?
Well in a nutshell,
Arc isn't actually running
DirectX 9 games in DirectX 9.
Instead, they're using a DirectX 9
to DirectX 12 translation layer.
This works because you can turn basically
any DX9 command into a
string of DX12 commands
which is great for compatibility.
But in the process you are
adding a buttload of CPU overhead
so much that any small background task
can significantly affect your frame rates.
Now, because of the extremely limited time
that we were given to benchmark Arc
before the embargo lift,
we weren't able to test a
wide variety of older games.
This is actually a strategy
that we've seen often
when a manufacturer doesn't
want you to look too closely.
Fortunately, we have a solution to that.
Tomorrow we are gonna be live
for hours taking requests
from our community and gaming side by side
on the Arc A770 and RTX 3060.
So you can see how your
favorite games run,
or if they run at all.
Because nothing at this
point is a guarantee.
Intel told us point blank that they knew
about the performance challenges
of Arc in older games.
And they had a strategy
where they were gonna price
this generation of cards
according to Hollywood perform
in a worst case scenario
or in Tier 3 games.
And I'm not gonna go as far
as to say that Intel lied
which would imply premeditated
intention to deceive.
But what I do have to say is
that these CS:GO results show
that they did not follow through on this.
I mean, charitably, we could say
that the Arc gets half of the
performance of an RTX 3060
though at 10 UDP it's more like a third.
So even if we're looking
at a $400 RTX 3060,
these A700 series GPUs
should be at most 200 bucks.
But if we go back to that
dye size conversation,
I mean remember this is a GPU
that is larger than a 3070
and built on TSMCs
cutting edge and six node
rather than an Intel's own fab.
So they can't exactly
give themselves a friends
and neighbors discount on the fabbing.
So if they went any lower,
they'd likely be losing money
on every card they sold.
And it gets even worse.
Unfortunately for Intel, who's
trying to position themselves
as the scrappy underdog
undercutting videos
monopolistic pricing,
we already have scrappy underdog at home.
It's AMD and their Radeon
6600 goes for about 250 bucks
and is able to truly trade
blows with the RTX 3060
without the in specific
DirectX 12 titles fine print.
And although AMDs software
hasn't always been fantastic
if our community feedback
has anything to go by,
the last couple of years have
been a real turning point.
And their RDNA 2 cards
have aged like fine wine,
getting better with
each new driver update.
I would hope that the
same will happen for Arc.
And we actually have
seen a lot of improvement
since its first outing.
Arc was actually impressively stable
for our first gen product
throughout our testing.
But when it comes to raw performance,
there are clearly some problems here
that can't be fixed without new silicon.
Like Intel's reliance on Resizable BAR.
ReBAR, as we've started calling it,
is a feature that allows for much larger,
more efficient data dumps between the GPU
and the system memory.
It's only available on systems
from the last few years
but for most people that's
not really a huge deal.
Because performance on AMD
and NVIDIA cards only improves
by anywhere from 1% to at most about 10%.
For Intel, on the other hand,
ReBAR is basically a necessity.
Performance can end up so bad without it
that Intel said in
their own press briefing
that if you don't have it
you might as well get a 3060.
With this in mind then, we
point blank asked Intel,
why the heck would anybody buy
an Arc GPU over the RX 6600?
To which they replied,
that the RX 6600 doesn't have
feature parity with the A750.
When compared to Radeon
6000, Intel claimed,
Arc has much better rate
tracing, AI acceleration,
and media encoders that make
it a much closer competitor
to the RTX 3060.
And okay, yeah. If you
care about those things,
they actually have a pretty good point.
In Ray Tracing titles
The A770 is a tiny bit
behind the RTX 3060.
And in Shadow of the Tomb Raider,
Intel's Xe Super Sampling
or XeSS ended up performing
very similarly to NVIDIA's DLSS 2.
So yes, Intel. You do
very much have a leg up
on AMD in 100% of the Strand
type games on the market
along with the other 20 games
that actually support XeSS.
But it's clear you'll
need to pull some tricks
out of your sleeves to get game developers
to adopt XeSS more broadly.
That sleeve trick, by the way,
is easy on our Short Circuit
hoodie, ltt store.com.
It's not just game super sampling either.
If you care about AI
performance more generally,
Arc is kind of excellent and here's why.
Traditionally, matrix
operations are done using a MAC,
or a multiply, accumulate, combine.
Which is okay at traditional workloads,
but can be pretty slow for AI.
On integrated graphics,
Intel has a fancier way
to MAC called DP4A where
it takes a 32-bit register
and splits it into 8-bit chunks,
allowing for four parallel operations
to be performed at once,
improving throughput by about four times.
The full-fat Arc cards like the A750,
take that to the next level with XMX
which allows you to do
multiple multiply accumulates
in parallel, which can improve throughput
by up to 16 times in theory.
And in practice where the
A770 absolutely slaughtered
the competition in Topaz Video Enhanced AI
without running into any of
the issues that we experienced
in our A370 M review.
Intel Arc also supports NextGen
AV1 encoding and decoding,
which is particularly
beneficial for streamers
due to its much higher image quality
at low bit rates compared to H.264.
We actually have a video coming up
that discusses using a low end Arc GPU
as kind of an encoding co-processor.
If you don't wanna
spend $900 on an RTX 47,
excuse me, sorry.
I mean 4080 12 gig.
Unfortunately, in more traditional
H.264 and H.265 encoding,
the RTX 3060 is able to handily embarrass,
even the top tier A770.
And the same goes for Blender rendering.
Though as a consolation prize,
Intel was at least able to
beat the 3050 in Blender
while AMD continued to make
its usual excellent case
for never using AMD if
you're a Blender artist.
Intel also made a good case
for not using Arc on Linux
for the foreseeable future.
Sorry guys. I know that
you had high hopes,
but currently Arc only
supports Kernel Version 6.
And Intel has said that they do not plan
on supporting Version 5.
Meaning that every stable version of Linux
is currently not supported.
To put this in perspective
for the non Linux folks out there,
this is basically like
Intel launching a product
but only having drivers for Windows 12.
Oh, one thing I haven't mentioned yet
is that there are both 16 gig
and 8 gig versions of the A770.
But the reason I didn't mention that
is that Intel's only doing
a small run of 16 gig cards
and the A750 is the far more
compelling option anyway
at $289 for nearly the same performance.
Now, thank you for that.
I'm going to do something
that might surprise you.
I'm gonna ask you, you fine
viewer of Linus Tech Tips.
You savvy source of tech support
for your friends and family
to seriously consider
Arc for your next GPU.
Because somebody needs to do it,
and it can't be your friend
who's shopping for prebuilt right now.
You do not wanna help them
troubleshoot random edge cases
on this thing, but somebody has to do it.
Because the last few
years have made it clear
that NVIDIA has no qualms
about gouging their customers
when there's a shortage or no shortage.
And the thing is that,
everyone says they want more competition.
But then they go ahead and
just buy the NVIDIA GPU
and hey thanks AMD for
keeping Team Green Honest.
Glad you exist, except when you
don't keep Team Green Honest
because you also like
to jack up your prices
and sell the crypto miners.
So there it is.
If you're the technical type
and don't mind rolling
the dice once in a while,
I'm asking you to give Intel Arc a shot.
You might not get as many FPS,
but I think it's safe to say
you'll have a more interesting
hardware experience
than a 3060 owner will.
You can even over clock the thing
or you could just ignore my plea
and wait for AMD's RDNA three to drop.
So you can pick up a GPU that was designed
to take on NVIDIA's 4000 series
instead of one that failed
to take on the 3070.
Just like I failed to
segue to our sponsor.
Nexigo.
If you're working from home
and are in need of a new webcam,
Nexigo has a wide variety to choose from
to keep you looking sharp
on your conference calls.
Whether you're on a budget
and need high quality video
or you just want the best possible webcam
regardless of the price,
their selection of webcams
and webcam accessories
will help you look and sound your best.
Even if you're looking for
something more in the middle.
Nexigo has you covered.
So take your webcam set
up to the next level
and get in Nexigo webcam
using the link down below.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
you're gonna wanna check
out our unboxing of the A770
over on the Short Circuit channel.
We get into a little bit more depth
about the different
kinds of connectors on it
and all that kind of good stuff.
Show the RGB lighting up.